each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
okay our next our next speaker is John
yard and John's gonna tell us about
exact synthesis of single qubit unit
Aries thanks Krista so uh some accepted
to talk to you guys about some research
that I've been doing for at least the
last year since coming up here to to the
main campus of MSR collaborating a lot
with with the Dean Krishna cough on some
questions in quantum circuit synthesis
so we'll mainly be talking about some
documentation of our research which is
in the archive here and the paper is
called a framework for exact synthesis
but maybe a more descriptive title would
have been you know exact synthesis of
kin of cubic unit Ares using quaternion
algebra arithmetic so so what's the deal
with what do we mean by exact synthesis
or more generally just synthesis of
quantum circuits so if you're gonna try
to build a quantum computer you'll have
some device that maybe has some limited
number of gates that it can do some
finite set and that's not really going
to be sufficient to do an arbitrary
computation so you're gonna hope that
this finite set can get you arbitrarily
close to any unitary that you might want
to do and then you want to get to it as
fast as possible so you can use as as as
few computational resources as as needed
in order to in order to run your
computation so there's a classic theorem
Sol of a Cateye of which says that if I
have some gate set and let's say it's in
SU 2 but really I could take any
constant size and it says that if I then
have some arbitrary unitary in SU 2 that
I would like to achieve but if I only
have so if this gates that just contains
some you know u 1
you asked for some finite set then I can
find some sequence of use so for any
epsilon that there exists some sequence
of length order poly log 1 over epsilon
such that if I compute let's say the
operator nor between you and u1 up to u
s1 that I can get this lesson epsilon
for n like that so this tells us that we
can efficiently approximate any unitary
in SU 2 with a finite set but when you
actually do the gate counts and people
did you get some sort of depressing
numbers but but it turns out that one
can do better in certain cases so
there's a paper from cat6 the boskie
phillips Sarna and it has some kind of a
scary title about hecka operators on su
2 but what they do is they construct
explicit expanding graph expander graphs
essentially from finding they have a
very nice gate set essentially that that
rapidly fills the space of all unit Ares
it actually grows exponentially fast and
then so they can get rid of this poly
log so I should mention that the you
know for general gate sets solve a
Kataya
gives you about about the fourth degree
here in this polynomial but you can just
get rid of the polynomial for certain
gate sets so so what is the gate set
that these guys found so it comes from
returning arithmetic okay so so what are
quaternion okay the tourney ins are
let's say you can think of them as like
a generalization of the complex numbers
but more explicitly you think of them as
some vector space over the real numbers
with a non-trivial multiplication
to find on it so so we have kind of four
vectors one and I J and K and these
satisfy some relations so I squared
equals Z squared equals K squared equals
minus 1 this formula was famously
chiseled onto a bridge by Hamilton when
he discovered the paternity ins in the
1800s and so so what's so special about
the returning interval all I should add
one more i J equals K and we all work
with quaternions all the time without
quite realizing it in the sense that
there's that we can view the quaternions
as some sub algebra of the two-by-two
matrices but not a complex sub algebra
but a real sub algebra so some real
vector space living inside here and
essentially the mapping goes like the
real numbers go to the identity matrix
and then I take I to square root of
Sigma X J let's just square root of
minus 1 Sigma Y and Sigma Z so these
guys here we call the pork the pure
quaternions
and in this setting they map to the
space of anti hermitian two-by-two
complex matrices and this scalar part is
just you know scalar real multiples of
the identity so one of the nice things
about quaternions maybe the nice thing
about them mathematically is that they
let you construct spin representations
to double covers so namely we have a map
so let me call I'll give a name for this
H for the Hamilton quaternions and so
there's a map the spin covering map
which takes you from so this little X
here means if the elements of the
quaternions that are invertible actually
it turns out that every non zero of
course pruning is invertible so this is
a non-trivial example of what's called
division algebra or division ring in
mathematics so
everything it's not zero has an inverse
and they go from these guys to so3 over
the reals and there's an explicit way to
do this and it's uh it's pretty simple
so what we do is we take this space here
of pure quaternions we view that as r3
and we act on this space with
quaternions so namely given some
quaternion in here we take it to the map
that takes a pure quaternion to q x q
inverse so it conjugates by returning
okay
and so namely this X here would be of
the form ax 1 I and it turns out we get
a two to one mapping well that should
say a many to one mapping so here we
have actually the real numbers are kind
of the kernel of this map right so
scalars do nothing because they kind of
commute through but the fact that these
are a non commutative algebra it's
exactly what allows us to get this
covering so so why go through all this
effort so what we can do is we can fix
the notion of integers inside the
quaternions and you get something called
the Lipschitz attorney ins and what
these are these are just put integers in
place of the real numbers okay so we
didn't do anything fancy there but it
turns out that inside this ring so now
we can kind of do a rithmetic in here
and we can also find some interesting
gate sets so namely the ones that these
guys analyze was let me call this map
something I want to call this R so it R
for rotation and so they gave these
gates R of 1 plus 2i plus or minus
TJ are 1 plus or minus 2 K so here's 6
gates this is your gate set so this is
and it turns out that this is these are
essentially in a certain sense this is
the best gate set that you might hope
for in the sense that it fills su 2 as
rapidly as possible I won't get into the
details of how one shows that but this
gate set was identified as a gate set
for quantum computing I think in like
2006 as a paper by Harrow rechtin Chang
and the they they noticed that well okay
so one thing I didn't mention about this
saw of a cat eye is that not only do you
get a sequence that grows like order log
1 over epsilon but you can find it in
time or start poly log 1 over Epsilon
but you can find it in time that grows
like poly log or Epsilon so here now we
have these sequences of gates that give
you just order log 1 over epsilon
scaling but this was just an existence
proof it wasn't known at the time how to
actually compile into such a gate set or
how to find the best one of this form
you know that can be generated by these
that approximates the given gates that
so or given a gate that you want so this
problem was recently solved in this
group in the last year or two by a nice
taper by uh by Krista and Yuri and Alex
and they showed how to solve not only
the exact synthesis problem in the sense
of given some target you know rotation
that you'd like to do that you know is
possible to do exactly find the shortest
circuit but they could also say given
you know an epsilon find like the
nearest or essentially the optimal like
you know next to nearest unitary that's
so if you have some you that you want to
do you have some epsilon ball measure
and appropriate norm and you know find
the nearest guy that is that can be done
with some fixed number n okay
sure right so I can describe it more
easily I think just in terms of
orthogonal rotations cuz I've worked it
out in the last hour
but what they wind up being actually is
it's like one of these guys and I may
get it wrong but be something like three
fifths all right yeah we can oh yeah so
so you can do this mapping here that I
said yeah sorry and maybe I should
mention another thing so there's a nice
formula so there's a notion of a of the
conjugate of a quaternion so q bar would
be like q0 minus Q 1 I minus Q 2 J minus
Q 3 K if Q was the same thing with
plusses and then this can actually be
rewritten as Q x q bar divided by Q q
bar so you can sort of think of this as
being able to work with unnormalized
unit ares that you can you know pull the
unit area off here so this is this winds
up being literally conjugate transpose
this bar operation right because it it
inverts the the anti hermitian ones but
leaves the hermitian one alone
and so yeah so so this was sort of this
was worked out in that paper but there
are other gate sets that people consider
besides just one this it's kind of
artificial and I believe that there's
some known ways to be distill they call
this the V basis for reasons that I not
quite sure why
oh really
I didn't know that okay so it's the V
basis so a much more popular gate set is
what we known in quantum information
theory as Clifford plus T so Clifford
plus T was sort of lacking a filter
neurotic interpretation up until our
work so I want to explain how that how
that enters the picture so
but before I get there I'll tell you a
little bit more about Lipschitz attorney
ins so let me call this L relations so
given any ring we write a little x up
here what this means in math is this is
called the unit group of the ring so
rings are rings are closed under
addition and multiplication but they
don't necessarily contain inverses so
this is all the invertible guys in your
ring so what's the unit group of the
Lipschitz quaternion order that she
winds up being what's known in math as
the quaternion group okay so this has
eight elements plus or minus 1 plus or
minus I minus J plus or minus K so in
quantum information we often talk about
the the power group which is very
closely related which is essentially
what you get if you tensor this with the
square root of -1 or if you allow
putting in the square root of -1 so in
other words just you know plus or minus
I times Sigma X Sigma Y Sigma Z or the
identity but I would argue that we
really should be thinking more about
quaternions and Powys because in some
sense the arithmetic comes out a little
cleaner no I'll try to say a little more
about what I mean by that so there's a
notion of so being an integer is
something that has a very concrete
mathematical definition that I'm not
really gonna try to get across you today
but what I'll say is that there are
bigger rings of integers inside the
quaternions that contain this so it's a
sort of this is a non maximal order in
mathematical speed and it's contained in
a maximal order called the Horwitz
patterns which look almost the same
but they look like this so so these guys
kind of live inside here as some finite
index of ring okay but why did we do
something like this well now if we ask
for the unit group of this order it's
slightly bigger and actually it winds up
being isomorphic to q8 semi direct
product with an order three element so
all this means is that I have a group
that contains the pattern ian's or this
quaternion group along with some other
order three guy that permits them and
maybe now is when it's good to draw a
picture so if you imagine acting single
qubit gates on the Bloch sphere what you
wind up doing is you permute the corners
of his cube it's so the qubit clipper
group if you will is actually in math
known as the as the the octahedral group
but it's also the symmetries of the
square and the octahedron is kind of the
dual poly tope to the earth sorry to the
cube and so what the quaternion group is
doing is it's just rotating the cube by
you know by a pi rotation about the x y
or the z axis but now we allow this
other order three guy right in here and
this is you could write down what this
gate is and I forget we're just that's
not hard to distract it so this group
here is actually known as the binary or
just the tetrahedral just a word about
binary versus ordinary tetrahedral so
the tetrahedral group is actually a so
this is binary so this would be as an
element of a so three of our but binary
is a double cover so that's an su 2 C so
so you need to be a little careful in
certain instances which one you're
talking about but for the purpose of
this talk don't worry about it so we
almost have the clipper group but we
only kind of have this this this
subgroup is the clipper group has if we
look at it as a subgroup of so3 it has
24 elements here we only have 12
ok so we're missing some but this is 24
but is a double cover
/ cute and you get 12 so where's the
rest of them where's the rest of the
clipper group where's T how do you fit
it in here and so to do this we need to
do a little more work and we need to
generalize further what we mean by an
integer so no Z the ordinary integers
these live inside of the real numbers
but they also live inside you know
intermediately the the rational numbers
okay and so the rationals and the reals
these are fields okay so these are
things where you can add multiply and
and you can also divide by any nonzero
element similar to the Criterion's but
now things commute okay so it turns out
that it's it's very useful to work not
at the level of the continuum but at
kind of this you know discrete type of a
field and to generalize to Q join the
square root of some or some other
algebraic number and for this topic I
won't get much beyond joining the square
root of two okay and there's a notion of
integers inside this this field is an
example of a number field let me write
it like this and so so what this is oh
it's just right up here again this is
the set of all a plus B root 2 where a
and B are in the integers and similarly
Q root 2 is the same thing with being
inside the rationals okay so they can
further generalize our notion of
quaternions away from allowing just just
real elements if we hide for the
Hamilton for Trinian's well we can
restrict it to a sub ring which now just
has elements with rational coefficients
in front of 1 I J and K or we can kind
of pick these guys so you can you can
really think of this as living inside
the reals in this and you should for
this talk at least so
so we can kind of define a new prefer
nians but I might just call each of them
too and you know this is defined as
before but the really interesting thing
is that we have this notion of integral
quaternions in here which I'll write a
script oh and they have a slightly
different form so you should sort of
think of this as some as some just some
discrete lattice that lives in eight
dimensions now right because he's one of
these guys there's in two dimensions if
there's an r2 or really in two copies of
Q so in q2 and so now we have the kind
of this eight dimensional discrete
lattice that lives in this kind of
higher dimensional generalization of the
quaternions and we can ask well what is
it
it's unit group and what not so the unit
group winds up being infinite but what
we have is so if we go to this covering
map here and if we then the integers in
like this we have our
in this case it winds up being so3 over
Q root to that we get now some finite
subgroup of here which is exactly of
order 24 equals Clifford and just just
to give you I can list some of them out
so I mean this right here and this right
here and these does these are all
elements that live inside this unit
group and again they're you should think
of them as being defined up to up to
scalars right because of this covering
map that that ignores the scalar
component and so it turns out we get the
whole clipper group in this way but
that's really not enough right because
we're after something that's going to be
dense then we know the Clifford group is
finite how do we get a dense subgroup
well we need to t gate so where's this
Clifford + T coming from and so so the
answer is this so I'll just write it up
here T is 1 plus root 2 plus K so if you
plug this guy into this map here
actually what you wind up getting I
think is it it looks like this it's like
1 over
and actually it turns out that the
entire image of Clifford + T is actually
going to be contained in a so it's gonna
be not contained in but equal a so three
yes so you hit the whole thing and now
having such a characterization of all
the things that are exactly
synthesizable is precisely what you need
in order to then take a step back and do
the general approximate synthesis
problem because now we know what the
target gates are that we want to try to
hit so you're sort of reduced to doing
some maybe complicated algebraic
optimizations over this algebraic group
essentially and um and then and then you
have a hope of solving the problem in
general so in the last few minutes I
kind of want to tell show you some other
examples of kind of how this kind of
picture can be generalized and it in
sort of a huge way and this is sort of
just the tip of an iceberg really where
in a sense just about every possible
gates that anybody's ever considered can
be explained in this type of a framework
and one can even go beyond cubits acute
Ritz and there's there's much
mathematical machinery that exists to do
that and we're actually having a really
fun time learning this stuff there's
some actual applications in mind so I
think that the people who developed this
stuff did it from you know from very
high perspective of it being just pure
mathematics without many applications
outside of perhaps cryptography so one
example would be Clifford plus T plus V
I'll just say so this V basis can fit
into this framework in in the same way
so basically these V gates just have the
same image or a same description via
this covering map but let me it's nearly
lunchtime and I guess I started a little
late I just want to say a bit more so
well I'll say I'll say a few things so
so first of all it's sort of helpful to
focus on so3 in the setting which this
is also isomorphic to the projective
unitary group okay well we ignore phases
and I know like in a lot of the
literature people do things with unit
errors and there's some overall phase
that we don't care about and but when
you're really doing the arithmetic these
phases can be a messy thing as anybody
who's kind of gotten deep into this
knows and so it's helpful and sometimes
to view things in terms of so3 but it's
also helpful to view things in terms of
unit errors especially we go to higher
dimensions that we can't kind of fall
back on this group theoretic accident
this is some kind of ongoing work on our
part and trying to understand things
that are known by some people but not by
us as well as we would like but just to
go back so I mentioned this here
so there was a characterization of the
exactly synthesizable circuits or unit
areas over clifford plus t that was
found by by clinic of mass love and
Mosca and actually they gave it in terms
of su - sorry you - over this ring
so this is the ring generated by the 8th
route's of unity
this is a 2:8 is sort of shorthand from
e to the 2 pi over 8 and by all powers
of 1/2 so you're allowed to divide by 2
and this is also kind of a natural
notion of integers in a certain ball
defying sense and so it can be sort of
difficult to make this work for some for
certain reasons in in other types of
theories and maybe I'll just mention yet
another kind of very very different
looking gate set that we hope will be
available naturally in systems with
topological order so one other way to
make a qubit is if you have some
particles some any ons interdict I find
two dimensions and your elementary gates
are essentially moving these guys around
so you know swapping gate these guys
like this but if we make time what it
actually looks like something like this
so it's a braid and as you move around
your circuits are things that look like
this
and the idea is that there's some group
at play here called the braid group this
has two so in this case B 3 meaning the
break group on three strands it has it
has two generators say Sigma 1 and Sigma
2 what they call them and this would be
R that got a twist of the first two
strands say let's say let's say
clockwise is Sigma 1 and a twist
clockwise supposed to the second two
strands will be Sigma 2 so I think here
everything's clockwise yeah Sigma 2 so
as an element of the braid group this
braid would be Sigma 2 squared Sigma 1
ok but now what we have so this is some
infinite group okay but there's we have
a representation of this group and let's
say you two already asked you to
and it turns out that one cannot so I
should say that that there was so so
Vadim and krysta and Alex and was there
anybody else on your paper so they can
they solve the approximate synthesis
problem for braiding a Fibonacci
antion's about a year or two ago in the
sense that they characterize a set of
exotica synthesizable unit ares and and
and also saw the approximate synthesis
problem in in a sufficiently nice way
and so one thing that kind of came out
of another aspect of this work that we
described here is is a way to give some
some orders than other quaternion al
tours that are a little a little
different than these ones who that also
naturally give rise to these brave group
representations and allow one to
principle characterize the images or not
in principle but allow one to
characterize the images in terms of
essentially algebraic group theory but
what is what's the order so maybe I'll
just leave you with this so what we have
is an order over or the quaternion
algebra base is q join of square root of
five okay and the order looks like this
that's Z the golden ratio
so we get this order the Fibonacci and
there's some kind of new features that
happen here
it didn't happen before so I didn't
really get into you exactly how the
quaternion arithmetic is used to do the
exact synthesis but maybe I'll just say
a word on that so so essentially we
reduce the problem - so given an exactly
synthesizable unitary you realize it or
you represent it as an integral
quaternion by by scaling so you can
change the scale and put it into this
integral ring right because it doesn't
care about this map doesn't care about
the overall scale and then from that
unitary so if it was the V basis case
you can kind of just do trial trial
division you tried dividing by any one
of the six gates and there were only one
that takes it down and that there's a
complexity measure so I didn't mention
this but this there's something called
the norm map of app returning and it's
just QQ bar and actually what this is is
it's just the Euclidean length of the of
the quaternion that you're working with
and it turns out that the that the norm
is going to be something like 5 to the K
where K is the number of V basis unit
errors that it takes to do your to do
your circuit in the V basis case so in
the in the Clifford + T case we now get
essentially the T count comes up because
now you get that the norm of some
quaternion that you want to synthesize
is something like like root 2 raised to
the K or maybe it's 2 and so this gives
you you can kind of read your T count
off and what you do is you can kind of
just try dividing by the different
conjugates of T by the Clifford group at
sea until you get down until until you
get down to something at norm one and it
turns out that the norm one guys are the
ones that live inside the unit group and
then so it
you're done basically but something very
different happens over here which is
that now the unit group is infinite and
actually all the options in the unit
group so essentially the whole image of
his breakup representation is contained
in the unit group really it's an index
to subject so it's all the braids that
you could get with an even number of
twists and so different methods are
needed to do the the exact synthesis and
so one can put to work methods from
hyperbolic geometry and at least in the
case of Fibonacci and other certain
related break group types of problems
that come from sort of well-known
topological field theories called
asks you to level K turned Simon's
theory and actually the arithmetic
groups that arise are things that are
kind of well known and have been studied
since the early days of mathematics are
called arithmetic triangle groups and
there I just said that these are the
groups that show up in the cases where
we know that we can do it with them that
with a given algorithm but for in these
correspond a certain fixed values of K
that I won't get into now more generally
some sort of higher dimensional methods
from Shinra varieties are probably
needed so it's probably time for lunch
so I'll stop there Thanks
great thanks John
are there questions for John though
besides the the let's say the efficiency
of the of the discovery of sequences of
gates that the materialized things
there's also the question of how many
does it take to approximate something
and it looks like the less abelian and
let's say the less congruence relations
in the algebraic structure you're
dealing with the more like an expander
the graph reachable unit Ares in K steps
looks and I think that's maybe I mean I
would guess that maybe is why turning
based things are more efficient than
merely adding adding adding algebraic
stuff to the integers you come in well I
think it's all because it's algebraic
actually so there's a there's a result
of a bore Ganon Gambhir from they have a
few papers one from maybe 2007 one from
2011 they showed that any gate set with
algebra whose entries are algebraic
numbers object gives you this
exponential expansion and at least in
principle there exist you know log 1
over epsilon approximating sequences but
they don't know how to find them in
general is that a problem or is that a
what you're depending on what you're
adding that route to what's the
algebraic structure you're joining it
that's all
doing observational storm to me there
are fair there are various deep
mathematical questions some of which are
open that have to do with the app
selects the rate at which you know
optimizing the rate yes and and I'm
still not a quite an expert but I I know
that even Peter Sarna I saw a talk
recently
I mean he he pointed out that in some
setting that they could prove something
was optimal but another setting they
couldn't so I think that even the
experts don't quite know any other
questions okay otherwise let's think
John one more time each year Microsoft
Research helps hundreds of influential
speakers from around the world
including leading scientists renowned
experts in technology book authors and
leading academics and makes videos of
these lectures freely available
you